bros
i wish i was joking but the minecraft
warden has taken over my base
i spent a lot of time building this base
the warden has kidnapped dark darksven
2.0
donkey my beloved donkey and punky my
beloved
bonky
this could be it i have not touched the
game since i paused out of pure
panic what is the plan what i do i don't
know i'll uh i think he might not be
after me
if i see him i will scream
oh god
oh god okay okay
he's there he's definitely there donkey
donkey
are you okay he's looking at me donkey
don't make a sound he knows
there he is
okay
now
oh god
oh god he's coming for no i can't do
this
oh god it's so i won't sleep in the lava
i don't know where i'm flying i could
die oh god i didn't think about this why
did i put lava in my base
okay we're fine
[Music]
he's taking my base
that son of a pig
you'll pay for this
thursman 2.0 must be so scared
you know there's only one thing to do if
someone takes over your base
you take over theirs i will find your
home an eye for eye mr warden i will
find your home
mikasa
er
oh
[Music]
i'm gonna take all your money
oh god this is a bad idea i have no idea
what i'm doing
no
i have no defenses
i'm not scared i wasn't scared i didn't
get to check his stupid chest i hate him
i hate you
we're going to dig around
oh diamonds
i don't have time for diamonds what am i
saying always time for diamonds
see you
i don't have arrows i forgot arrows
can i hit him
oh
oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh this is for jurgen
this is for smurgan 2.
oh my god he doesn't die
can you die
maybe he can't die
[Music]
he can die i changed mine
give me your chest
i'm deleting everything
i'm deleting everything from the scene
candles he's got candles wow he's so
poor he only got bones and candles but
an idiot i'm gonna give him a vial and a
note that says you're lame and i hate
you i'm removing all of them
whoa whoa
whoa
okay maybe there's more money to be made
we gotta sneak
bros
i'm using my totem if i oh
oh oh yeah
oh this is perfect
uh you see i have a plan
you may have think oh he lit scandal
sword then lit's candles how cute he's
into candles
this is so cool are these new blocks i
think i've seen those they look like a
creeper face i'm scared of making any
noises
yeah
you didn't hear nothing oh god
oh god it's fine just shove them away
that's right it's easy as that one two
three no wooden it shall be damn you get
a lot of xp from these yeah give me that
xp
what have i done what have i done
it's so dark and scary now
oh there he is
not too happy huh well neither am i my
plan is to blow him the f up okay
you get my house
i explode your ass those are the rules i
didn't make them i mean i okay
everything that you love will die do you
understand
maybe if i just build a bridge of tnt i
feel like this is a very bad idea
extremely bad idea but maybe
yeah this is good you can't reach me and
i can plan all my tnts
yeah yeah keep following me keep
following me see what happens it feels
very dumb and very stupid to do on a
hardcore basis that you spend so much
time in but i hate you
it's personal yeah keep following me
it's personal now if i get pushed down
from here i mean there is a risk of that
but i'm not i'm not worried
um that god it's so it gets so dark if i
see skeleton oh spider
this is bad can the spider come up here
spider don't come up here don't spider
spider i speak to you i plead to you oh
they fight spider fight for me
spider love
oh god
spider don't do it spider
[Music]
my lover
i love him
oh god i hope mojang knows how many kids
are gonna get nightmares
all right we need to work on a faster
basis here i think
luckily torches don't uh
ignite tnts i know this uh
i know this because i know this okay
it's a pro pro tip oh look at him in his
little cant can candles
no
i'm on his loot he's so poor you know
whoa they have lights here they're
activated by noise
what that's so how how does that
redstone work
how does that work that's got to be new
that's kind of sick all right so he got
a sick barbecue grill i give him that
dude this place is huge
so very big and you are a yard damn this
looks insane dude can you imagine with
shaders though look at my bridge of
death you're gonna die
this is like a castle
[Music]
duh yeah well i didn't it didn't
register okay look at this
okay
uh-huh
uh-huh i saw something over here best be
careful now
oh gosh i hear a skeleton i don't want
to veneers
that's it a book and some candles oh
[ __ ]
bro bro not the time bro trust me bro
not the time bro no bro bro bro
seriously i'm serious
oh god
i've done it again
god damn it
where is he
[Applause]
okay let's throw a snowball at him
[Laughter]
idiot
snowballs are really good at it that's
awesome i found your weakness it's time
it's time mr warden okay perfect this
one
is for
god
[Music]
yeah
let's go
[Music]
now i gotta save my friends
let's go
oh god
he's still there
my planet
oh god oh that's my redstone
my plan is sneaky
dark friend ducksman are you okay
darksvin
torksen dark sweat dark sweat it's me
are you okay
okay don't worry i'll get him
bucket
bucket
it's me
don't be scared
i'm going to get
arrows
and i'm going to kill him
so hard okay okay okay this is a scary
move
but it's only as scary as scary of
itself
bonky said that
let's go
i've been infiltrated donkey
oh
here we go
see there
new plan thank you for the emotional
support but i need new plane we fly to
ceiling now
oh damn oh god damn it i forgot i can't
see anything don't fly into lava don't
fly into lava i don't know where i am i
don't know where i am
where am i i have no idea oh god there
we go
he makes it so difficult
i hate him how do i deal with ace i need
to get up
but it's too dark i can't see anything
[Music]
perfect yes
now where is he
he's trying to take a bath
yeah
oh i got you now mother flop no one's
gonna buy your bath water mr warden
you're dead
yes okay and now
i gotta get rid of that goddamn curse
object as fast as possible yes
oh
hallelujah
we are safe
donkey
you made it
for those of you who don't know we
haven't watched this serious donkey has
been stuck in that mine cart for 20
episodes
and probably more i don't know how many
hours but dude i think it's time we get
you out of that minecart why don't you
say
[Music]